congratulations are in order for one of
my fellow panelists this week after
their enthusiastic work dogged
determination and tireless campaigning
finally paid off
our hearts nearly burst with pride when
we spotted you amongst a sea of blond
blue force at the qe2 Center for the
biggest announcement of the political
calendar now we know you won't want us
making a big fuss about it
but we just have to say Rachel Johnson
well done for finally making it as the
sister of the prime minister to make
sure you don't forget our slowly pledges
now your sky-high we were crowned I've
got you a little present
which you have to wear that's why your
chest story I'll just hold it here I'm
not gonna wear it throughout everyone
can have a good look yes which brings us
to my topic just yet because coming up
before you Greg argues Boris could be
out before he knows it I'm saying
Britannia should once again rule the
waves Carole wants more support for
those living with dementia and Rachael
says women need to stop being undermined
by men who think they know better now
remind me Roge Oh what is it your
torpedo rage Oh what is it you're
talking about this week guess what I'm
talking about this week it's a funny old
world isn't it and may I be the first on
the panel to congratulate our new prime
minister Boris Johnson and wish him the
best of luck
he'll need lots of it in the next 98
days after which according to statute
will leave the EU Deal or No Deal do or
die especially after that bloodbath of a
reshuffle and the creation of a hard
brexit war cabinet that won't
necessarily unite the party let alone
the country still I can't help feeling
proud of him only 55 men or women have
made it to the very top more people have
been to space as we
buckle up for the ride of our lives I
salute him for making his own moonshot
on politics and landing safely for the
moment at 10 Downing Street may I now
speak from the heart
as a sister say what you like about
Boris but he never makes personal
attacks he may sack from cabinet those
who backed others for the leadership but
he generally remains polite and
courteous whatever anyone says about him
you may not agree with absolutely
everything on you PM says or does but
let's try to play the ball not the man I
know it's heavy but he's my brother
[Music]
actually I'm beyond excited at his
election I really am you know we've had
three years of hopelessness of
hand-wringing
of doom and gloom of ministers try to
terrify the life out of our population
that we know we couldn't survive on a
river can't leave dear you I am so ready
for Boris I can't tell I want his
enthusiasm right now steady Karel his
big bold promises I want to hear what I
want the enthusiasm I want I just want
it all and you know what he he's not a
stupid man he knows he's got 99 days
there may be 98 I have lost count and to
make this work and he's he's he's
pledged everything on it and I love that
about him well I love the fact he staked
at all and he said this is what I'm
gonna do and he knows what it means if
he doesn't do it he knows what's gonna
happen if he doesn't do it and I just I
want that kind of bravest you know I
listened to his speech yesterday and and
my heart was bursting because we need
that kind of enthusiasm in this country
that we needed and you know a lot of
people like I'm Greg I'm sure will say
it can't happen it's almost like a lot
of people don't want it to happen but
gonna talk about what can I do in in
Greg's topic yes yeah I do but I just
we need can we keep to what the theme of
what I wanted Rachel I mean are you when
you consider Kara's obviously very
excited about the harder exit that Boris
is going to inflict not even on her or
maybe not all ideal but Rachel can I are
you I we all know the personal is
political but can we make the political
slightly less personal I don't think
there's a but in that sentence I mean of
course the personal is political and
especially in this case and I think that
you know this is slightly awkward this
conversation given that you are his
sister and I think that's one reason for
the sort of Johnson dynasty to not be
involved in media management of
reputation management can I just say for
the record this is the only media I have
done around Boris's Premiership and rise
to becoming in Downing Street I have
turned on everything else except for the
pledge there you're very lucky and she
is a person in her own right I mean this
of course yes but the reason why I think
you can't separate is because we know
that personality of the Prime Minister
actually counts for a lot in the
particular way that our politics is set
up and we also know that Boris Johnson
has lied he habitually lies he's lied at
least twice and been fired from jobs
over it you know he's made bigoted
comments very recently including very
recently about the LGBT community about
black people about Muslim women who
reported an increase in hate crime after
he said those things
he has been careless enough to ensure
that a woman who probably extended the
detention of a British woman in Iranian
prison and he has been disloyal to the
extent that he has been prepared to
throw one of our key diplomats under a
bus so of course it's personality trait
you will affect but it's the caliber of
a person isn't it and that will affect
his politics for it so for asking for a
separation I think is yes thank you the
reality is I'm more on Carol's side than
I'm you if you are against Boris Johnson
you're always going to be a Bond spear
dancer Boris Johnson I would like to
point out and I would say I think it's
far more important where you're going
than where you've been I amazed if any
of us could actually say we've not had
problems in our lives
I've been sacked from jobs probably all
of us around here at times been
sacrilege of it same reason for her bit
for lying to your boss
so many recent politicians don't live it
are you really the politician don't live
with them great camp
I'm cleaning you now if Boris Johnson
cured cancer I'm not saying you
necessary but people like Rachael not
still still would blame me for not
having that speech Esther was one of the
most impressive her because not only did
he did he lay out the problems he has to
solve he gave solutions to those
problems and Tereza made it not yeah I
got sex as a training manager at Marks &
Spencer but it wasn't for like trainee
manager okay I was sitting in the qe2
when they made the enact the Declaration
and Brandon Lewis is the chairman of the
Tory Party actually stood up and before
he made the announcement of who'd won
the vote he said him he gave a plea to
the party he said please can we be nicer
to the incoming Prime Minister than we
were to the last should we be should we
be well first of all I give you some
credit for I think defending your
brother and saying look let's be nice to
him should we not think that criticise
him I'm just saying that's not make it's
ad hominem as it has been take a look at
this clip of your brother I want you to
consider this kipper this kipper which
has been presented to me by just now by
the editor of a national newspaper who
received it from a skipper smoker in the
Isle of Man who is utterly furious
because after decades of sending kippers
like this through the post he has had
his costs massively increased by
Brussels bureaucrats who have insisted
that each kipper
must be accompanied by a this a plastic
ice pillow
now what we know about that occurs is it
wasn't a possible bureaucrat it was a
Westminster bureaucrat to impose
holy evening me you go back to his
period work a long time ago but working
as a journalist in Brussels and he did
stories like that all the time some of
which were true and some of which
weren't and in the end I got fired for
no no no no let me finish the minute I
you cannot divorce someone's personality
and what they've done and what the from
their job now I agree with you I don't
care what his sexual relationships have
been about over the years either I think
that is all irrelevant but you do have
to look at the things he's done in work
and say well is he the right person is
that the right person
but I I do pay some to read you because
I think you know if you if your sister
won't defend you just picking up from
that which i think is important because
in brussels where i was and my husband
does one point is for an editor he was
writing these stuff about you know
they're gonna blow up the Berlin Wall is
it a law plan to rule Europe and what
we're seeing really is the final result
of those stories the calm which actually
created your skepticism became Agra
Thatcher's favorite journalist you know
that he found the tides of euro
skepticism with those articles with the
leave campaign and now he's reaping the
world we got this and so what we had you
not think that he bears some
responsibility for those as it were I
can't I don't want to say lies but you
know he and I think you know there was
that there was a piece written by Peter
over baldness we could work with you
brother for many years and he said and
this is what interests me he said he has
one of the most politically nuanced
brains he's ever come across
he said he's one of the most brilliant
men he's ever come across he said and I
think this is incredibly important for
the job to come he said that Boris
delegates responsibility to other people
he doesn't want to do everyone's job and
and he's not frightened to surround
himself by clever brilliant people
because he has a brilliant mind now that
to me is a very good recipe for a prime
minster what obon did say though he said
he could be one of the best ones we've
ever had but he does have some flaws
that could mess it up and that's what my
sense rachel
wants to come in just because we seem to
be sort of sliding over this lack of
truthfulness as though it's it doesn't
matter and let's just look at you know
public opinion on this this is from a
YouGov poll that was taken just a few
days ago so it's recent do you think
Boris Johnson is untrustworthy 58% of
those surveyed said yes he is
untrustworthy trustworthy 20% 23% don't
don't know so it doesn't matter it
matters that the prime minister of our
country has told so many lies in his
life and in his career these days ago
even in the campaign his leadership he
is one of the bravest politicians you
will ever come across London riots 2011
he gets back he goes down to Clapham
with someone who was then Home Secretary
Theresa May and was senior police
officers the mood of the crowd turns
really ugly
and I saw it I don't blame Theresa May I
don't blame police officers they all
turned away
what if Boris Johnson do walk straight
up to the noisiest protester offered out
his hand and said now what can I do to
help that is extraordinary bravery if he
shows that bravery now getting breasted
over the line we will give great thanks
to the fact that he's there